bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france ce soir vous êtes signataires
d'une tribune parue ce jeudi dans
libération qui pointe du doigt je sais
que la politique bipolaire du
gouvernement expliquez-nous pas loin de
quatre mois et nés dans une vie qui est
scindée en deux quasiment normalement la
journée on vit avec un travail ou moins
de télétravail que qu'au début on vit
avec des transports on vit avec des
commerces on vit avec les écoles qui
sont on a une vie qui est complètement
normal en journée et par par contre le
soir le week end on a une vie sociale et
culturelle qui est complètement l'arrêt
ne voit plus les gens on ne va plus au
théâtre on bâcle au cinéma on ne prend
plus le temps de se décompresser et cet
état de fait qui peut être acceptable
pendant quelques semaines là ça fait pas
loin de quatre mois et il s'agirait
taxation comme attendant l'été pour un
treuil les clés tels protocoles
sanitaires ont été mises en place pour
accueillir dans les lieux culturels
c'est devait rouvrir ces prochaines
semaines
il ya des protocoles qui sont
relativement bien établie depuis un
certain temps dans l'est pour tout ce
qui est spectacle assis pour le
spectacle à cl au théâtre et au cinéma
des protocoles qui marche bien elle
aucun gloucester dans un cinéma dans un
thé là bas ça marche bien on peut encore
les renforcer encore l'imaginer gratté
par ci par là une place entre deux je ne
sais pas quoi faut limiter les
interactions avant et après les séances
c'est un des trucs importants donc il ya
des choses qu'on peut faire pour
éventuellement renforcée et protocoles
mais la base les protocoles existe pour
les musées c'est encore plus grossier
pour le musée il n'y a pas un médecin
qui ne vous disent qu'il n'y a aucun
problème pour visiter des musées
aujourd'hui toutes les conditions sont
respectées il ya évidemment aucun souci
et même pour le pour le l'extérieur pour
les événements extérieurs même en deux
bouts avec la manière dont le don
l'extérieur réduit les probabilités de
de contamination on peut complètement
alors des protocoles qui tienne la route
dès demain offert des événements et
alors que parce que vous expliquer la
réticence du gouvernement à rouvrir ces
lieux culturels comment est-ce qu'il se
justifier auprès de vous
acteurs du monde de la culture pour
l'instant fait tout ce passe comme si
ils avaient décidé que toute la toupie
tout l'effort doit être portée par les
activités sociales et culturelles
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas d'autres
gouvernements en europe qui fait ce
choix là c'est à dire qu'on a vu en
allemagne en angleterre ils ont fait
baisser drastiquement les niveaux de
contamination
on est aujourd'hui en dessous de dix
mille carats quotidien on a le maniement
d'angleterre alors qu'on est à 25 ou 30
en anglais en france parce que on a tout
arrêté
c'est en arrêtant tout pendant une durée
réduite de six semaines quatre semaines
six semaines qu'on arrive à vraiment
baisser les taux là ce qu'on a fait ça
reste d'entre eux on a dit voilà la vie
professionnelle productive la
consommation ça fonctionne comme
d'habitude mais en revanche tout ce qui
est social et culturel on l'arrête
on voit bien que oms a des conséquences
psychologiques et psychiatriques très
lourde le nombre de deux des états
dépressifs chez les jeunes a doublé en
un an
en revanche il n'y a aucune raison de
penser que ça va ça va suffire puisque
puisqu'on voit bien que ça ne marche pas
ça marche parce qu on ne réduit pas qu'à
l'exception culturelle française nous
semble me semble vide de sens
aujourd'hui comparé à ces pays notamment
européens que vous citez qui ont alors
lieu culturel ouvert
c'est presque une exception culturelle
française à l'envers on est dans une
année sans doute aujourd'hui le pays
qu'a fait la plus grande différenciation
entre ce qu'ils considèrent ce que le
gouvernement considère comme essentiel
et ce qu'il considère comme non
essentiels à d'autres pays en europe ou
dans le monde qui est fait telle
distinction
quel regard que vous portez sur un le
mouvement d'occupation des théâtres
c'est là la meilleure façon peut-être la
seule de sart entendre aujourd'hui da
par les autorités c'est pas la seule
l'une est aussi une voix une autre
manière de le faire
mais aujourd'hui je pense que on à
l'illustration que les acteurs de la
culture sont vraiment vraiment
demande un truc qui bouge coiffer je
pense que le l'espèce de statu quo sur
un temps très très longue qu'on
connaisse il est plus supportable mais
puisque les roselyne bachelot jean
tordeur ce matin ses déclarations c'est
plus possible de dire on prend les gens
qui souffrent c'est plus ça dont on a
besoin d'un plus besoin de compassion
maternitantes on a besoin de décisions
politiques fortes
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne eric labbé cofondateur de
maisons message